eight eight eight eight oh her dad looks
sad are these actually her parents do we
need men no do we need men honestly no
these women are so stupid where do you
go to get your car fixed where do you go
to do anything men literally do the
hardest jobs in society men no why cuz
they
suck
[Laughter]
how what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to my reaction series today
we're going to be watching an awesome
day of watching women get humbl uh
before I start don't forget to like the
video and also get yourself a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt on your way in
let's go you guys think all sports
should be gender neutral yeah yeah why
all right these women have to have a
brain CIB too I play volleyball here in
England no no no no no no no no no get
the man out of her Sports get it out get
it out it's fair I don't know do you
think it's fair to have boxing gender
neutral yeah do these women look like
they play a sport I mean the one on the
right is so skinny and the one on the
left is fat neither of these women have
competed in a sport their entire life
I'm an athlete guys no no no no no I
don't want to see why not I think a girl
can kick a guy's ass and a guy can kick
a girl's ass for sure really yeah for
sure why I just think that that like a
girl could definitely do
it huh think
[Music]
again my ex-boyfriend of 6 Years love
him really good guy the last year of our
relationship I started cheating on him
with a guy in LA and that guy was the
one who told me break with your boyf
from move to LA was he cheating on you
too or he's a good boy why did you cheat
on your six-year relationship I was so
bored and so young and just like when
you're that young it's like you don't
know what you want in life and like in
the moment it seems like a good set up
and you think you're happy and content
and then you reach like 2021 and you're
like oh like I have a lot of Life to
Live and like I didn't want to stay in
Nevada and then I met this guy who was
like my dream guy who was like so hot
and like my ex-boyfriend was 6 years we
stopped having sex like I wasn't
sexually attracted to him it was just
like we were so comfortable and like
family and like roommates at that point
um but like just there was no sexual
romantic aspect to it so then I met that
guy yeah and guys sometimes that happens
in marriage or in law I mean at 6 years
you're damn near close to a marriage um
and this is why men fear this kind of
stuff because one day you might just get
bored I mean it doesn't sound like there
was any real problem she just got bored
and of course he's a good guy that's why
she cheated on him with a Chad because
she wanted to live out her life and find
herself she also does not take
accountability for being unloyal and
instead calls her boyfriend boring
hopefully she did a favor to that guy by
leaving him what is it
eight eight eight eight oh her dad looks
sad are these actually her
parents starting out disappointed with
eight or you just kind of like surprised
to a lot of people are disappointed by
eight wow I guess eight don't hate eight
don't hate yeah eight don't hate I can't
hate over the eight obviously you are
why does a body count count get into it
the sadness in bro's eyes when he heard
the word eight at first bro wanted to
scream his heart out but then bro
realized that you can't take the stick
out of the quicksand once it has been
inside do we need men no do we need men
honestly no do we these women are so
stupid where do you go to get your car
fixed where do you go to do anything men
literally do the hardest jobs in society
need men no why cuz they
[Music]
suck
how is that how you look at me every day
when I put my ear pods
[Music]
[Laughter]
in absolutely not I would never date
anyone in the public I ever never have
honestly I've dated guys that make good
money I've never dated like an insanely
wealthy dude what's good money pull up
your account I my phone is dead okay
what is what is good until you can pull
up your account is a couple million
enough maybe yeah isn't that wild like
nowadays the the the market is so
inflated that to get a 31-year-old girl
you know it's funny though you need to
have multi-million dollars like to get a
ran through 31-year-old like sweatpants
buring bag
damn to have multi multiple m in the
bank I know that's insane you can't just
you can't just be funny and have 8 inch
Hammer
anymore do you do you hate women no no I
love are you sure I do I love women
what's your relationship like with your
mom great that's what they do to me too
oh you're
psychoanalyzed with my mom really she
hugged you when you were little I was
just talking right before this like
right before I walked in she was I was
why do you find that so hard to believe
I'm feeling a little anger misogyny she
resorts to gaslighting and pulls out the
misogyny card on him because he called
her out for being a 304 if a man calls
out a Modern Woman for her well and this
chick can't even deny it they had a
podcast where they talked about all
their sex stuff literal podcast [__]
then he suddenly becomes a
misogynist can I
[Music]
get are you not going to buy a drink
come on I know you beening at me
all buy she's literally like so hard
anding
I can she have your number then no a
girlfriend unfortunately so I have your
number then why got a girlfriend is it
she not going to be happy
with keep pay for drinks and he's been
harassed it's been sexual
harassment you
never
yeah now gay do you hate your
mother a
boyfriend that's what they would do to
Kevin Samuels he's gay he's
[Music]
gay come on yeah because if a man
refuses to be a s and pay for your
drinks then he has to be gay he may have
lost a few customers that day but at
least he didn't lose his self-respect
and stayed loyal to his girlfriend oh my
God this for me person but with my job
like obviously a lot of men just tend to
jump to sexualizing me so I you
sexualize yourself please stop with this
please if a man is truly interested in
me I want to see that with him taking me
out on dates and getting to know me as a
person outside of my job and wanting to
help me I like how the I know I've seen
that girl on the right before I know I
like how the porn stars are complaining
about men sexualizing them like really
really
that don't you guys think it's unfair
for you to say say that it's unfair for
a man to sexualize you guys when your
occupation is literally titled
sex I think if a man's brain is that
small that he can't wrap his head around
like work versus real life then he's not
worth but your work is not traditional
work you the one that took something
that's real life intimate and loving and
turned it into works that's what you
need to
recognize no as of the last maybe 40
years but the rest of humanity treated
it as something in and loving and for
years now you've turned it into a career
and something for you to make money off
of so yeah there's no it makes sense
that you're completely desensitized and
you're never going to understand you
attract what you are modern women put
themselves out on the internet and then
wonder why weirdos and creeps walk up to
them like what else do you expect a good
high value man who treats you like a
normal woman when you are out here doing
something that's not normal but then
they Dodge accountability and resort to
blaming the man luckily a woman put her
in her place and called her out for her
degrading actions like the woman in the
next clip feminists doing that's
empowering yet you're relying on creepy
disgusting men who think you are
disgusting and trash to ironically pay
your bills which is probably the most
degrading thing in the entire world
whereas actually if you were in an
office it would be a lot less degrading
you could actually have respect in an
office and do not get offended when you
come into the dating pool and dating
world and you are seen as a low value
woman in my eyes you are Every Man's
eyes you are and uh don't get offended
when people don't want to marry you
don't want you to be their girlfriend
you're going to hit the real world
eventually um it's just amount of time
and no one with any level of like a
brain would ever respect someone who
does that no it's true like who the hell
who the hell wants to date a sex worker
that is the biggest red flag like you
might as well only fans on a woman's
resumee is like a felony conviction on a
job resume no no no no no no a lot to
impact I don't go on the internet and
expect people not to judge me you cannot
be a sex worker and expect people not to
judge you wow yes that is so true I
agree with that so just don't complain
about the outcome go get your bag yes
and then deal with no one thinking that
you're a valuable human and also
bringing just shame to your family name
as well it's yeah I think dads should
disown daughters that have that to see
women like this call out other women for
their actions because it's them who keep
modern dating from succumbing to
complete degeneracy protect women like
her at all
costs yeah guys what a world 2023 it's
actually so crazy when I think back to
high school how much Society has changed
just in like five seven years like there
wasn't of like foreign workers like that
and now it's like not an uncommon thing
it's fairly common it's not weird to no
one and just in a couple of years and
like even randomly like how make chicks
that do escort stuff that doesn't even
include all of that but let me know what
you guys think in the comments like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel I'll talk to you next time